[Music]
100 years ago archaeology was for the
rich
50 years ago it was for men
but we are expanding it to the world
i wish for us to discover
the millions of unknown archaeological
sites around the world
by creating a 21st century army of
global explorers
will find and protect the world's hidden
heritage
so how are we going to do this
they had a big idea to change the world
but they couldn't do it alone
so my wish is my wish i wish
my wish and now
here's my wish
[Music]
i am an archaeologist and i specialize
in using satellite imagery to map
ancient landscapes the really fun title
is space archaeology you of course want
to record maybe how thick something is
which you can't measure from space
whether that's soil whether that's snow
when i won the prize i'd present this
completely crazy wish
i had to present the case for
archaeology to the world why does it
matter so what
the reality is there aren't enough of us
scientists we've got to give more people
opportunities to become explorers
global explorer is an online
crowdsourcing platform that allows
anyone in the world to help map ancient
sites by looking at satellite imagery
and it's this idea that everyone in the
world can make a contribution to science
it can be anyone
[Music]
i'm doris jones i'm 90 years old i live
alone except for my two kitties
and i need something to do i play games
i like sudoki
and i play mahjong with friends on
friday
and i'm an armchair archaeologist
why don't you want to work
down
down let's work
doris is one of our top contributors
she's a space archaeologist she's looked
at many many many thousands of tiles
people like her are just a gift to
global explore right now i'm living out
of tile but well it has a wall
probably for animals
but it has a number of what look more
like trails and roads
i'll go to the next one all you have to
do is look at an image and look
carefully and you see
that there could potentially be a new
site there
[Music]
doris just has this passion and
energy and excitement for exploration
she's able to give back and really
contribute in a meaningful way
[Music]
hi
i'm actually crying right now because
i'm like overwhelmed with emotion
well thank you see your face and say
thank you i just really admire what
you're doing
and i really enjoyed the program
when did your love for archaeology and
paleontology and science start
well in the middle 50s my husband and i
were in the backyard
digging a garden it was late fall we
were getting ready for next spring and i
saw a strange looking white rock on the
ground
i picked it up
and he said let me see that i showed it
to him and he said you know what this is
so i told him i didn't
he said this is a fossil
and and we took out to the creek and
started looking for fossils from then on
there was no turning back
that's wonderful
so then i
collected for years
and after all those years of course i've
got all those memories so
but that's the type of thing that it's
not just hunting the fossils but the
experiences and you just learn and
really just live and enjoy
and i think the fun is in the hunt
you know it's like
well like the rainbow you know the end
of the rainbow is a pot of gold so
global explorer
was kind of my rainbow
and even at my age
i can continue to hunt for lost
civilizations
i want to tell you about some of the
incredible things that have happened as
a result of your discoveries we're now
beginning to take
thousands of features that people like
you have found and we're sharing them
with archaeologists
who work in peru
they're beginning to confirm the things
the crowd has found so in other words
the platform works
ultimately this technology is helping us
to rewrite our history
we need to know our history we're all
one people's
it's all our history we're all here on
this little ball of dirt
i believe we have barely scratched the
surface in terms of what's left to
discover
and
the greatest story ever told
is the story of our shared human journey
but the only way that we're going to be
able to write it
is if we do it together
[Music]
you